a two-day final farewell to Rashard
Brooks will begin this afternoon in
Atlanta
Brooks was shot dead in a confrontation
with two police officers ten days ago
both officers now face criminal charges
the one who fired the fatal shots Garret
Wolfe is accused of felony murder as
jeff PGA's reports some Georgia
lawmakers now say the local district
attorney is rushing to judgment it is
time for the District Attorney of Fulton
County to step aside
that's congressman Doug Collins he is
echoing calls from the Atlanta Police
Union for a special prosecutor to take
over the Rashad Brooks investigation you
cannot prosecute cases until the
investigation is over
you don't do it for politics your job is
to find justice for everyone not race
not class not anything else but district
attorney Paul Howard astana lead
offended his decision to charge officer
Garrett Ruffin Devin Brosnan yesterday
he vowed he wouldn't step aside the
spotlight on police officer conduct has
grown substantially since George Floyd's
death while in the custody of the
Minneapolis police four weeks ago this
weekend a shopper confronted one of
those officers Alexander King as he
bought groceries he is out on bail so
you're out of prison just and you're
comfortably shopping income foods
as if you didn't do anything I'm mad I
wouldn't call it comfortably out the
state getting necessities I don't think
you should have that right I don't even
think you should be out on bail in an
interview with 60 minutes Minneapolis
police chief midoriya arredondo defended
his decision to fire all four officers
immediately the lawyer for the other
officers is saying they were rookies and
they were just following the
instructions of the senior officer
I don't craft policy or make policy
based on years of service I expect in
our community expects your humanity and
your moral compass to rise above and so
if you fail to intervene either verbally
or physically to me you're complicit
meanwhile the County Detention Center
where Derek Chauvin sits in jail is now
facing discrimination charges of its own
eight officers of colors say they were
prohibited from entering or working on
the floor where Derek Chauvin was being
held the day he was arrested in a
statement the superintendent of the
Ramsey County Jail in Minnesota says
that decision was reversed in 45 minutes
let's take a look at what the
superintendent said writing recognizing
that the murder of George Floyd was
likely to create particularly acute
radicalized trauma I felt I had an
immediate duty to protect and support
employees who may have been traumatized
I realized that I had erred in judgment
and issued an apology back here in
Atlanta the viewing for Rashard Brooks
begins later on this afternoon here at
historic Evan easer Baptist Church Tony
all right Jeff Jeff begins for us thank
you very much